in 2017 North Korea went on a missile
launch bonanza first into the Sea of
Japan in February then its first ever
intercontinental ballistic missile on
July 4th happy birthday America
and 18 other missile tests plus a
cyberattack on 150 countries
disrupting everything from banks to
hospitals no five nine but pretty
effective according to North Korean
media Americans on internet websites now
have nuclear phobia kim jong un's
threats of war weren't new but this time
they were echoed by the US on twitter by
the way which seems like a bad way to
reach someone in North Korea but hey
tensions were at an arguably all-time
high and then something changed out of
nowhere after the deadline Kim jong-un
announced he would send two athletes to
the 2018 Olympics and not just that but
with South Korea under a unified flag
his sister and an entourage of
suspiciously enthusiastic fans also
traveled to the South missile testing
suddenly stopped and Kim even met with a
US Secretary of State he also left the
country for the first time as supreme
leader to visit Xi Jinping in China and
then the biggest news yet both North and
South held an inter-korean summit for
Kim hugged the South Korean president
even stepped on South Korean soil I mean
that sounds like a story from the onion
it's a complete 180 from non-stop
missile launches two friendly smiles and
hugs in just five months for many this
is completely bizarre for others it's
the obvious result of successful foreign
policy but what looks like desperation
or backpedaling or even foolishness is
really just the continuation of a
long-standing very rational very
calculated survival strategy with a
twist so what exactly is going on and
how will it end
Kim jong-eun has one thing on his wish
list stay in power for him power means
wealth and luxury and safety for his
family so if that's the goal you might
wonder why not just you know show out
and enjoy those things he appears to do
the opposite risking everything by
poking the biggest guns he could find
that's why so many see him as genuinely
crazy and the media of course has no
interest in alleviating that word worry
is their business model but it's not
true
Kim inherited a very poor hungry
primitive country if he does nothing the
country will wither and fail no one to
make Swiss cheese or basketballs and
becoming a self-sustaining or just not
terrible country would mean economic
reform reform brings better living
conditions for everyone which you might
expect would protect Kim from revolution
but it's just the opposite a population
that can just barely feed itself only
has time to do exactly that revolutions
are feats of strength not weakness
what's really dangerous is a taste of
the good life a peek at what they could
have reformed could eventually make the
north as successful as its neighbor but
it would mean goodbye for Kent so he
needs resources but can't afford
economic reform the solution is the same
kind of socialism the country has always
dreamed of and never delivered shared or
resources aka four and eight and how do
you get handouts as a totalitarian
country with death camps but
intimidating a superpower like the
United States is hard if they had six
hundred billion dollars to rival the US
military they wouldn't need to scare
them anyway so instead they skip the
entire tech tree straight to nuclear
weapons a single nuke is the ultimate
shield against war and uproar which also
makes it the perfect negotiating tool
the thought of denuclearizing North
Korea is so attractive the world will do
anything for the slightest chance to get
it including forgetting 15 years of
failed foreign policy just two years
after Kim jong-un took power a former
exchange student in Pyongyang and now
expert and rail and cop wrote a book
called the real North Korea Co 40 wrote
sounds familiar when North Korea are
unhappy they follow the same routine
they first manufacture a crisis and
drive tensions as high as possible when
newspaper headlines tell the world that
the Korean Peninsula is on the brink of
war the North Korean government suggests
negotiations the offer is accepted with
a sigh of relief
giving North Korean diplomats the
leverage to squeeze maximum concessions
it's the North Korean version of the
hero's journey the same story told over
and over and over again but because we
want to believe we buy it every time at
any given moment
Kim is either in total assault mode
creating fear and therefore our
desperation for negotiation or total
charm mode convincing the world is a new
man he just needs some financial support
man this cycle of aggression charm and
repeat is happening now but it's not new
at all
there have been six other rounds of
negotiations North Korea agreed to
abandon their nuclear program in 2005
they got what they wanted and then broke
their promise but this time is a bit
different their nuclear program has been
building up for almost 40 years to one
goal the ability to reach the US
mainland until then there was no
realistic chance of their giving up the
program it's their one and only
deterrent the only key to Kim's life
lesson learned from Iraq in Libya on
November 28th they tested the whole song
15 proving they could reach anywhere in
America and two months later they joined
the Olympics and turned on the charm
that timing is no coincidence they
accomplished their goal no need for more
missile testing now it's time to cash in
get all they can from halting the tests
while keeping even if it means hiding
the ability to target the u.s. they
couldn't have scheduled it better xi
Jinping was probably pressuring them to
relax and tensions were extremely high
with the u.s. the administration really
wants to show its strategy worked giving
Kim enormous negotiating leverage it's
possible the talks will fail or succeed
with flying colors but here's my rough
prediction Kim will excite the world
with concessions but most will be
completely symbolic cheek smiles and no
concrete promises he'll agree to stop
nuclear development which they no longer
need in exchange for some American
military
concessions that also benefit China who
would prefer America back out of Asia
little to nothing will change inside
North Korea more of the same terrible
oppression and real reunification won't
be possible anytime soon but American
and South Korean politicians will
declare a huge success but so will North
Korea who finally got a seat at the
table has its security guaranteed plus
maybe some economic benefits exactly as
planned when he next finds himself low
on cash or in need of something without
the attention to get it well he'll know
exactly what works and by the time North
Korea makes its next move you could be
well on your way to making yours
everything you saw in this video I made
in a graphic design application called
affinity designer it's far cheaper than
Adobe Illustrator but still a bit
intimidating for beginners so a great
way to learn it is with a class like
this one on Skillshare it'll walk you
through making digital graphics and easy
to follow bite-sized videos everything
from colors to custom shapes brushes and
exporting if you want to make videos
like this one this is a great way to get
started and with a premium membership
you pay one low price for all the
classes you want so you can find the
perfect one for you
jump around or take multiple at a time
there are classes on photography finance
app development and something I'm gonna
check out calligraphy something that's
really cool is that you can browse other
people's projects for inspiration I mean
look at all the cool lettering people
have made who took this calligraphy
class and for poly matter viewers the
first 500 people to sign up with a link
in the description get two free months
of unlimited classes thanks again to
skill share and to everyone who gives it
a try
[Music]